le festival international de la bande
dessinée s'est ouvert à angoulême et la
grande question cette année est de
savoir si l'on pourra bientôt lire sa bd
en 3d sur son ordinateur
certains dessinateurs sont séduits
d'autres effrayés par ces nouvelles
technologies
le lecteur lui s'est habitué à ces
nouveaux mondes et serait plutôt
demandeurs thiery stampfler marc felix
quel type de bande dessinée nos enfants
vont ils inventer dans le futur ce ne
sera pas seulement un changement de
génération mais peut-être aussi de
l'univers les quelques 10 millions de
jeux vidéo vendus en france chaque année
auront forcément une influence
consommateurs habitués aux jeux en trois
dimensions et à leur rythme frénétique
ces enfants auront ils encore la
patience de se plonger dans une bd
traditionnelle
aujourd'hui les dessinateurs comme fait
bertranne utilisent l'informatique
son album mais galex fera sans doute
date
enfin toujours d'un petit croquis
extrêmement rapide tête à toto qui vous
sert simplement à visualiser ce dont
j'aurais besoin de la scène en question
après j'utilise toutes les ressources de
l'ordinateur pour des balades et à
l'intérieur de ces décors sur lequel je
n'aurai plus qu'à installer mes
personnages
malheureusement pour moi bonjour la
machine j'ai une page blanche comme
quand je pense à un papier blanc et il
faut tout faire pour partir de zéro et
tous fabriqués chaque objet le fabrique
comme si je prenais un morceau balsa et
que je découpe et les petits objets pour
les mon petit pot de peinture et je les
payais ses possibilités fascinant ne
séduisent pas tous les jeunes auteurs
sélectionnés angoulême issu de la
génération informatique jean 18 ans et
nicolas 20 ans préfère tous deux la
bonne vieille planche à dessin et sa
matière vient pas quoi travailler
travailler avec l'intermédiaire d'une
machine à voie sèche que j'arrête longue
date aigles le décès directement nicolas
qui a créé une ville imaginaire peuplé
de pitbull devrait séduire rapidement
les éditeurs lui aussi revendiquent les
méthodes traditionnelles
un dessin au crayon 40 plus révélateur
du caractère du dessinateur et c'est ce
qui c'est ce qui intéresse les gens qui
utilisent les bd c'est comme ça qu'on
arrive à à différencier les auteurs
visitant la superbe exposition qui lui
est consacrée le père de blueberry
imagine que la technologie peut créer
une nouvelle interactivité avec le
public rentre dans mon oeuvre puis je
vais te promener dans un labyrinthe
qu'elle labyrinthe de mon coeur ou de
mode haut de mon chapeau
ma vision ja ça peut être un jeu
désireuse de s'adapter aux années 2000
sans perdre sa diversité
la bande dessinée cherche de nouvelles
voies